he's the Commissioner major league
baseball mr. Commissioner to you or Rob
Rob Manfred the baseball commissioner
the 10th Commissioner of Major League
Baseball thank you for joining us
commissioner glad to be here so can I
call you rob you can okay cuz I I don't
want to go no off script here and then
somebody's saying you're disrespecting
the Commissioner's Office you said it
once okay that's it you're good now but
you want my guys to call you mister
Commission does your wife call you
commissioner
no do you get that clean out the garage
how many times did it take you to get
that signature on major league you're
the major league baseball well you know
it actually was a funny thing the day
after I got elected I went to the office
and the person who was running our
licensing department came down he had a
whole stack of index cards and about 10
pens and he said you need to figure out
you know you need to sign a whole bunch
of times and decide which one of these
is going to be the signature it goes on
to ball cuz I got elected in August they
needed to start making baseballs for the
following season interestingly I
approached it from the perspective of
replicability right can I do it again or
do it again standing up on a round
surface and so that's where we ended up
could you sign the baseball that do
people ask you to sign the baseball that
has your signature already on all the
time but but you've already signed it I
know I can you let's see if you can
replicate that so there's a technique
here did you know this no I learned this
from Joe Torre you know it's hard to
just hold it out there and write on it
so you kind of put it against your leg
okay so that it's stationary alright and
you know Joe has one of the best he does
great have great penmanship yeah I think
it was that Catholic school education
yeah let me see if I could turn it
around
how'd I do Paulie put that on eBay right
now I don't know what we're gonna get
for that but that's uh let's put it out
there is a market on eBay by the way if
you serious all kidding aside did you
know I've like everybody your signature
as a market mine snuffle I don't know
but it's not that impressive how often
do you talk to other commissioners in
other sports
we get together as a group a few times a
year the four major sports and you know
one offs probably you know once twice a
month you know we we had a deeper
relationship with the NHL because of the
meteorites deal that we did with them so
I talked to Gary more but I talked to
all of them you know once every couple
of months we're talking a lot now mostly
about gambling yeah okay where do we
stand with gambling like howdy it feels
like everybody wants to get their piece
and then once they get their piece we've
settled that and then then all of a
sudden we have gambling well the way I
think about it is this you know it's a
challenge and an opportunity right on
the challenge side you know there's been
a lot written about you know us lobbying
and but the fact of the matter is we
talk to sports in Europe when we
realized this was coming so the single
biggest mistake you can make is not
being active in trying to determine what
the legal frameworks gonna look like
from an integrity perspective we need
laws whether they're state laws federal
laws whatever that allow us to protect
the integrity of our sport that's our
job we're not gonna delegate it to some
regulator in New Jersey or whatever with
all due respect you know we care more
about it it's what we're about on the
other hand it's an opportunity we know
you know just you don't even need
research but there is research
fan engagement can be improved through
gaming people are more interested in the
sport they consume more of the sport so
you want to take advantage of that
opportunity without letting gaming
become too intrusive you know Gaming can
go over the top you kind of saw it in
the draft Kings vanduul advertising Wars
right that's an example of it and so we
want
find that sweet spot where fans consume
more of our game without the gaming
becoming overwhelming could you see
where I go to the ballpark and I can
place a bet there well you know that is
the easiest answer in gaming because all
this gaming is gonna be mobile yes and
so once you know that you don't have to
answer questions about our they're gonna
be kiosks or Windows or any of those
things the fact that no matter is you're
gonna be able to do it on your phone and
you can't stop that whether you're in
the ballpark or out of the ball but you
can capitalize on it as the commissioner
and your owners can capitalize on this
and having you know something like a
room where you can go in and place a bet
look there is no question that gaming
presents an economic opportunity for us
I don't think we see it as an engagement
sale of you know intellectual property
like statistics opportunity we will not
be directly in the gaming business when
people try to connect petros to gambling
easy right I mean I think it's actually
another easy question that you get asked
all the time no matter what happens with
gambling in the United States there will
always be a rule that prohibits unfilled
personnel managers coaches players run
office personnel from betting on the
sport it feels like I was told by
somebody that I trust that there's
there's still more to Pete's story that
has never come out and maybe it'll never
come out that's a Pete Rose question you
know I just don't know no but this is
evidence that baseball has oh I would
say this I've never found it necessary
in any without singling out Pete in any
disciplinary matter to write down
everything you know about what's going
on I just don't think it's usually
productive any chance of for a baseball
team in Vegas oh yeah I mean I I think
Vegas is a viable expansion alternative
I think it's big enough but once you get
your stadiums with Tampa and Oakland
done mm-hmm are we looking at expanding
then after that yeah and you hit it just
right Dan I mean Oakland and Tampa have
to get done before anything else happens
um I would then like to get to 32
I'd like to get to 32 it gives you
schedule flexibility because force work
better than fives in the schedule just
in terms of being able to lay the games
out it also presents an opportunity so
you do eight divisions with that's what
I would do but you know I mean that's an
issue that would have to be discussed
but whether it's a sir force you still
get that schedule flexibility it creates
a possibility of some realignment that
could help in terms of travel and maybe
best of all it gives you a lot of
flexibility in what you would do with
your playoff format you got a lot more
options on your play off and where are
we looking at with possibilities here oh
yeah you know we're lucky in this regard
and I mean it is an embarrassment of
riches whenever you talk about cities
you know if you leave one off or mention
one you know that gets that City off you
know one direction or the other but you
know in the u.s. you could Vegas
Portland Nashville Charlotte all viable
alternatives for us Montreal certainly
maybe someplace else in Canada I think
you know Mexico depending on how far
down the road we are could be another
possibility for as a franchise Dynamics
AX come the Red Sox Yankees next year in
London next year in London really
excited about that
I you know I'll take two things about
that that have already happened that are
indicative of what this event could be
first of all both owners Hal
Steinbrenner and John Henry flew to
London to do the press conference with
me that's how excited the clubs are
about this this is an unusual thing you
know they don't usually do that kind of
travel secondly in the first call me a
liar for 24 hours I believe we had
57,000 pre registers for a 55,000 seat
stadium so you know we think it's going
to be a really big event we hope it
gives us a foothold in Europe and you
know it when you want to make a splash
you take your biggest rival yeah and
that's what we're doing he's the
Commissioner Major League Baseball Rob
Manfred joining us here in the man cave
baseball ships we saw where Bryce Harper
the other day in New York thought he had
a base hit ended up hitting into a
double play and frustrated didn't run
out the ball right you know we've seen
these ships now
is there anything the Commissioner can
do wants to do will do with these
baseball shifts well I I think it's a
broader issue than shifts the way that I
think about it is this Dan you know the
new thinking in the game the use of
analytics have produced organic change
in the game and I think that it is
pretty clear that the owners want to
have a conversation about whether we
need to be more proactive in terms of
rule changes in managing what is
happening organically so shifts just one
example I don't mean to single that out
there are other issues out there but you
know is it time we understand why people
are doing it we understand that you know
it provides an advantage but is it time
that we adopt a rule that limits the use
of them I mean it has been a you know
just an astounding change I think in
less than 10 years we've gone from 2,400
pitches a year where you see a shift to
over 36,000 this year but how could you
limit it well you'd limit it by I mean
the easiest way and a bunch of
suggestions you know two defenders each
side of the second base bag maybe make
sure that the infielders all I have to
have at least one foot on the dirt
there's a variety of things that you
could do maybe a dog fence where there's
only so far they could go and then they
get jolted is that yeah I mean look you
don't want to be what you don't want to
be intrusive you don't want to be in a
position where you're changing what we
regard to be the greatest game in the
world with or without the issues
surrounding shifts and other things we
think it's a great game on the field by
the same token you know it has changed
and it's important I think it's
incumbent upon us to talk about that
change and decide you know if and when
it's appropriate to interfere
what other rule changes do you see on
the horizon well I you know the things
that people are talking about and that's
different than do I foresee a change you
know I think the other one that people
talk a lot about is the use of relief
pitchers and it does have a lot of
effects right if starters go
a shorter period of time that affects
the way they pitch during that shorter
period of time right all-out effort it
frankly it affects the marketing of the
game right the individual player most
prevalent in a broadcast is a starting
pitcher if he's out there last that
changes you know the star power of that
individual pitcher so you have to think
about all those issues and then the
toughest one toughest one when you
change your rule in baseball is to
figure out what the rule change is gonna
do what's the effect of that change so
they take shifts right I assume you know
that was a huge change people start
shifting a lot what everybody said you
know you go back and look is oh this is
not a big deal right because the hitters
just gonna go the other way the hitters
are gonna adjust their narrate athletes
and they're they'll just go the other
way well they were right about two parts
the hitters will adjust they are great
athletes but the adjustment was
different than what everybody expected
now instead of going the other way they
decided to go up and over and why'd they
do that because what the analytics told
them is even the discounted opportunity
to get a home run okay you know it
doesn't happen as frequently is more
valuable than that hit going the other
way in terms of actually winning a game
so you gotta think through what's gonna
happen in it you know I got great move
talking about this before we came on the
air you know when you don't when you
haven't played at that level you have to
have players former players former
managers with major league experience
around you to help you try to think
through what is a really unpredictable
outcome the d-h if I said you had you
could you could make the decision right
now yeah oddly I'd leave it alone you
don't want it internationally no I the
reason I want to leave it alone is it
gives everybody who interviews me
something that's about it's relatively
easy
yeah it's easy no that's that's really
not the truth the truth is it feels like
it's coming well I you know I don't
really agree with that I think that you
would know better than I but I just have
it felt like it was coming because
there's more offense yeah I hear but if
you look at the two leagues I don't
think people see the d-h it's the extent
that we have an issue with offense if
that's your issue if you look at the two
leagues I'm not sure that you would
reach the conclusion that the DHS you're
in and I can keep stars in they can be
around looser look there's value in that
although you know the D H has changed a
little bit right I mean you know years
ago the Dave Winfield's the Don Baylor's
we kept all modern guys around they're
different kinds of players now if you
look at who the teams are using as their
DHS it's it's a little different than it
was III think that it's a good thing for
the game to have that debate number one
number two you know extinction is a bad
word right I mean it's just sort of a
word you want to stay away that's final
it's harsh you know there's something
about it yeah and you know if the
nationally drops the d h that form of
baseball becomes extinct adoption yeah I
said drops I meant adopts but if they
adopt it you know the the pure form of
baseball that's played in the National
he becomes extinct and I you know I
think there'd be some reluctance how are
you capturing the youth I know I know
this is a big initiative for you but
this this group this generation or these
parents that were listening
how are you attracting those kids you
know I think this is really interesting
we thought getting kids to play was
gonna be really hard and what we have
found is that investment will in fact
draw kids to the game so what's that
investment look like it's all under the
umbrella play ball it's everything from
one-day events that the Conference of
Mayors run with us where you try to
introduce people to the game with you
know drills and quick interaction and
then a description of playing
opportunities where can you play Little
League where
you play if you're 14 years old where
are the opportunities everything from
that up to the MLB academies where we
are providing elite level training in
underserved areas places where there
just weren't fields and coaches to get
kids to play we have a safe game that
provides tremendous playing
opportunities that teaches great values
and we we've had a tremendous amount of
success you know the biggest problem in
sports to me and it really is a societal
problem is that overall youth
participation in sports and I'm not
talking about baseball all sports is
declining it's declining because of the
interest in technology and electronics
over the last three years and these are
not our numbers these are industry
association numbers only one major sport
has grown in participation over the last
three years and this includes soccer
lacrosse all the things people talk
about its baseball we've grown at an
average annual rate of 6% over the last
three years in the face of declining
participation baseball still the most
played sport by children under 12 in the
United States and you know the trick the
trick is being where kids are and being
willing to put money out there to
provide them with playing opportunities
how do you respond when somebody says
the most popular are the best player in
the sport
the only publicity gets is the publicity
that he's not getting publicity and
that's Mike Trout you know it's
interesting I actually read about this
topic bill shaken had an article this
morning in the LA papers you know
publicity player marketing and I've said
this to players so I don't mind saying
it here you know the player marketing is
an important function but in order to do
it what do you need a player yeah and I
think if you read Bill's article you
know there's a malign one of the points
he makes is you know Mike if mike has
made certain decisions about how he
wants to play and what he wants to do
with the rest of his life and
that affects the profile that you're
gonna have if you want to be the most
famous player as well as being probably
the best there are certain things that
you have to devote time to and you know
that that's a lifestyle choice for
players having said that I do think it's
really important for the sport broadly
defined to market its players the game
is about the players I think that the
way you build your brand and you build
your fame in today's world has changed
it's not enough to be the best on the
field you have to be prepared to gift
and social media access via social media
and you know it's something that we're
gonna make a genuine effort to try to be
of assistance to our players on favorite
baseball player growing up Mickey Mantle
you know I I was really you know
sometimes you think back on your life
and you think well maybe this was meant
to be so my folks drew I grew up in
upstate New York
my folks drove my sister my brother down
to New York for a weekend a baseball my
dad was a huge Yankee fan it's 90 it's
August in 1968 right so Mantle's at the
end that's it yeah but we've been
watching because they had cable you know
in upstate New York yet cable early
because of the whole circus University
thing you know you that they
experimented with cable in the valleys
and up oh yeah yeah that is actually a
historical fact believe it or not anyway
so is the YES Network before the other
there was cable before there was really
hated anyways so we go down and the
first day they're playing the twins and
they lose to the twins three to two but
Mantle hits a home run from each side of
the plate they scored two runs he had
two solo shots turns out it was the last
time he ever did it so pretty
you know pretty amazing first baseball
at live baseball experience if you think
about do you got memorabilia
you know I this is funny I I did a
little event with President Bush after I
was elected and this was the last
question he asked me he was asking me
questions in front of an audience and I
said you know if I answer this
everybody's going to think
made this up but I'm gonna tell you the
truth I I was in the stadium the night
after 9/11 when he threw out the first
pitch yeah and he signed a dozen
baseball's and I ended up with one of
those baseballs and of all the things
I've been given over the years it's the
only thing I've ever kept that's the
only piece of ever that's the only thing
I've ever kept so if I go into your
office no other memorabilia in there
yeah no yeah well I take that back I
dare bud signed a ball CEO Lee signed a
ball that I haven't that actually sits
in my office I take that back you you
you you asked a good question that
proves I wasn't telling do you have the
keys to the Hall of Fame no see if you
wanted to go there and just like what if
I wanted to go there and ram around Jane
Clark is a really wonderful woman I'm on
the board and there is you know they do
do a back office tour okay in the Hall
of Fame that you know is phenomenal as
the collection and the exhibits all are
it is literally mind-boggling what they
have that they can't you can't display
it all at one time yeah but the
collection itself would you grab if he
you you can only grab one thing on the
way out you know what this is gonna be a
funny answer so I took my I took my kids
there they're now in their you know late
20s and 30s when they were young and my
son was tremendously interested in golf
and they had on display the club
championship trophy from I think it's
Leawood Country Club in Westchester
County the Babe Ruth one right
it's great to see and Congrats with the
success with the youth programs around
America and we appreciate your time as
long I'm glad to be here I was happy to
do it he's the commissioner Rob Manfred
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]